diehard Democrats and assorted
nevertrump furs have developed a severe
personality disorder they don't reason
they rant and a lot of you that were
bitching and moaning last night and
being morally self-righteous you are the
bad actor so save your breath alright
we're not going to divert our eyes this
president lies more than any other
president and the United States well for
more than two years now most have lost
any sense of individuality and they've
all defined themselves almost completely
in their opposition to President Trump
they live for any headline regardless of
how ill founded that spells trouble for
the president and if such news would be
bad for America they don't care as long
as it's really bad for Trump or a member
of his family or maybe his inner circle
they identify as anti Trump or never
Trump on social media and are so
invested in their conspiracy whack-job
theories and negative narratives about
him that a paralysis has set in they
cannot move toward deeper thought or
introspection or heaven forbid
contrition when it turns out as with the
Muller case they got it all wrong no
evidence of collusion no problem they
revert to their old Trump is evil
narrative they maybe tweak it a bit and
then they proceed to the next attack
what's happening is that the Attorney
General working hand in glove with the
White House is gaming the system to
frame the narrative Donald Trump is
legitimate he's a legitimate tyrant he's
a legitimate dictator in waiting they're
taking a victory lap for not being
felons and then this from the political
stage of our age I don't need the Muller
report to know he's a traitor I have a
TV well form our and his ilk villains
and heroes are predetermined by them and
new information in no way will disrupt
that narrative now this dynamic is also
at play in the case of actor and race
hoax choreographer jussie Smollett
today we learned that all of the charges
against Smollett have been dropped
following a deal with prosecutors at the
Cook County Attorney's Office after all
we've learned about this case the two
Nigerians purchasing the ads and the
Rope used in the alleged assault the
police saying Smollett sent threatening
letters to himself the actor had the
gall today to maintain his innocence and
invoke his mom for sympathy
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I was accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time
he's a Baghdad Bob of race hoaxes and
presto with that his brand rehab was
under way but make no mistakes I will
always continue to fight for the justice
equality and betterment of marginalized
people everywhere oh that's true if
marginalized people include other
purveyors of fakery and hate crimes
fraud he's a super hero in that regard
for sure and of course the media
themselves in denial are always there to
provide a much-needed assist it was an
overstep by the police department to
come out how does he ever get a fair
trial when you have the superintendent
going on Good Morning America or
blasting him there's also the question
about how the Chicago Police got so
duped the narrative is once again
changed from victim you know to villain
back to victim we may never really know
what happened on the street that night
in Chicago hope think of how often
liberals have derided conservatives as
know-nothings anti-science anti facts
yet two left-wing fanatics if your
variant Lee anti Trump which small it is
facts don't matter at all forget the
fact that Smollett made an outrageous
charge to advance his career in his
profile and forget that the hoax a cat
attack could have incited racial or
political violence in the city and
forget that he sent the Chicago Police
on a wild goose chase the left is always
quick to forgive their own the studio
that puts on his show Empire released
this statement
chessy Smollett has always maintained
his innocence and we are gratified on
his behalf that all charges against
have been dismissed translation were
gratified that this celebrity got off
with community service for his crimes
and that there will be no more
repercussions for our liberal friend but
thank goodness there were a few who
called out the state's attorney handling
of this celebrity crime for what it was
a complete injustice my personal opinion
is that you all know where I stand on
this do I think justice was served no I
think this city is still old an apology
but they chose to hide behind secrecy
and broker a deal to circumvent the
judicial system I stand behind the
detectives investigation and at the end
of the day this mr. Smollett who
committed this this this whole period
even Clinton loyalists rahm emanuel not
running for reelection had had enough
mr. Smollett is still saying that he is
innocent
still running down the Chicago Police
Department how dare him even after this
whitewash stared still no sense of
ownership of what he's done he says that
in fact he is the wrong in this case is
there no decency in this man and sends a
McClair message that if you're in a
position of influence and power you'll
get treated one way other people be
treated another way there is no
accountability than in the system the
deep sense of outrage and disgust even
liberal Rahm Emmanuel is expressing
there should but won't be what we all
feel every fair-minded American about
the Trump Russia collusion hoax this is
really the tale of two hoaxes one
perpetrated by Smollett on the city of
Chicago the other perpetrated by
anti-trump political partisans in the
media on the entire country the small
and hoax world the city but the Trump
hoax had both national and international
implications it could have affected
policy and may have likely tilted the
2018 midterms and has already destroyed
several lives one of the Muller victims
will actually be joining us later on in
the show as we've been arguing for
months
there must be consequence
for bad actors in and out of government
innocent people who are unfairly
targeted deserve justice and so did the
American people whose money is wasted we
need accountability and transparency
across the board a good start would be
the public release of both the small at
Grand Jury report and the full Muller
report then we'll see who the real
victims are it even when we do do not
expect the rabid left to leave their
denial comfort zone and that's the angle